- What is a meme, if
not a joke persevering?
Sound vaguely familiar?
What is x, if not y
persevering is a templated meme
stemming from the poignant
or cheesy line from "WandaVision."
- People took that
template and ran with it.
Templates like that began
as formulaic cliches.
"30 is the new 20,"
"Whatever floats your boat,"
and now have become culturally pervasive.
From public service
announcements to TV shows
to city taglines and
even political slogans,
they're everywhere.
But what are they exactly?
These adaptable cliche
frames are called snowclones.
They might look a little
bit like algebra problem,
solving for x and y,
but this is no y equals mx + b situation.
It's more like Mad Libs.
Let's give it a try.
Not me. Hmm.
Not me asking my little
sister about TikTok trends
because I'm already out of touch.
Not me using a snowclone to
try to explain snowclones.
It's giving millennial
attempting to appeal to Gen Zers.
It's giving trying too hard to be funny.
It's giving Cher?
It's giving is a popular snowclone
that became even more ubiquitous
when Shawn Mendes used it
in a now viral video from late 2021.
- It's giving.
It's giving Cher.
- With celebrities like Lizzo joining in.
Even more interesting, there
was a homophone pun shift
from Cher, the Goddess of
Pop, to share the verb.
And speaking of homophone pun snowclones,
I would be remiss not to mention
how I'm a big fan of Dune,
Dune the absolute most
for the smallest laughs.
I could go on and I will.
So hold onto your bucket hats
because we're about to word-nerd
like we've never word-nerded before.
I'm Dr. Erica Brozovsky,
and this is "Otherwords."
(light music)
- [Announcer] "Otherwords."
- In a 2003 blog post on Language Log,
linguist Jeffrey K Pullum solicited ideas
for the linguistic phenomenon
of a multi-use, customizable,
instantly recognizable, time-worn,
quoted or misquoted phrase or sentence
that can be used in an entirely open array
of different variants. (gasps)
In response, economists
Glen Whitman bestowed
upon us the neologism snowclone,
derived from the journalistic
cliches referring
to the number of Yupik
and Inuit words for snow,
and, of course, combined
with a pun on snow cones.
So the term snowclone is pretty recent,
but the concept goes back
further than you might think.
Julius Caesar is known
for a number of things
though the first one
that comes to mind is
probably getting assassinated,
which sticks in our collective imaginary
due to "Beware the Ides of
March," and "Et tu, Brute,"
courtesy of, you guessed it, Shakespeare.
However, besides getting got,
Julius Caesar was remembered
for the phrase "Veni, vidi, vici,"
I came, I saw, I conquered.
And now as a snowclone, I came,
I saw, I x'ed we see plays
in both the English and
original Latin versions,
like veni, vidi, Visa, I
came, I saw, I shopped,
or veni, vidi, Velcro, I
came, I saw, I stuck around.
And, of course, it's heavily
used in all sorts of media,
from album titles to movies.
- We came, we saw, we kicked its (beep).
- [Erica] When our old
pal William Shakespeare
penned his most famous
and most quotable line,
"To be or not to be,"
he probably didn't
realize that it was poised
to become one of the most
recognizable cliche phrases
of the next few centuries.
- To swing or not to swing.
(gentle music)
- And Shakespeare will be Shakespeare,
so, of course, he does have a few more.
"Much ado about nothing."
"Frailty thy name is woman."
"My kingdom for a horse."
"A rose by any other name."
In his 1637 philosophical
and autobiographical treatise
"Discourse on the Method,"
Rene Decartes wrote, "I
think, therefore I am,"
or in modern terms,
I don't exactly think so I ain't exactly.
While the phrase itself
is commonly repeated,
it is often snowcloned
such as in the 2015 film
"I Eat, Therefore I Am,"
or the two books on Goodreads
called "I Drink, Therefore I Am,"
one a wine guide and one about sobriety.
Philosophy is a funny thing, isn't it?
During the 19th century,
eight-year-old Virginia
O'Hanlon wrote to the editors
of the New York Sun to ask
about the existence of Santa.
So from editor Francis
Pharcellus Church's response,
"Yes, Virginia, there is a Santa Claus,"
we get both yes, x, there is a y,
and a little Christmas magic.
Another popular snowclone comes
with the 1939 film "The Wizard of Oz,"
where Dorothy and her friends are fearful
of what they might face
in the Haunted Forest.
"Lions and tigers and bears, oh my!"
It has since been adopted by journalists
as a prime cliche for
headlines of all sorts.
In the late 1960s,
"Star Trek" gave us a
special sort of snowclone.
Dr. McCoy says to Captain Kirk,
"I'm a doctor, not an engineer,
or mechanic, or bricklayer."
In the I'm an x, not a y format,
Dr. McCoy fills in the y
as the context demands.
Most snowclones originate
as a consistent phrase
that has been modified,
but here it's snowclones all the way down.
The rise of the internet in meme culture
has caused an avalanche in snowclones,
from alternate words and NFTs
to engagement announcement parodies.
I mean, how else do you
explain Boaty McBoatface
being the number one choice
when the British public
named a polar research ship?
And snowclones aren't limited to words.
In the right context, shapes
can fill in the blanks.
The iconic I Heart New York logo,
created by graphic designer Milton Glaser,
has been adapted into an
I, shape, x snowclone.
Sometimes it's still a
heart and another location,
but oftentimes we can see
some creative license,
like I food cart Street
Food, or I shamrock Guinness.
So why use snowclones?
In one simple phrase,
you're showing affiliation with
others who use the snowclone
through a digital inside joke
that is a shared piece of popular culture.
They're efficient forms of communication
for those who understand the context,
and oftentimes they're funny,
which is just an added bonus.
Put simply, humans crave connection,
and memes just do it for us.
And hey, if using snowclones is wrong,
I don't wanna be right.
Before you go,
our friends over on It's
Lit! are launching a podcast.
Hosted by the amazing Princess Weekes,
"It's Lit! [Unabridged]" features
all your favorite literature topics
and thoughtful funny conversations
from amazing authors.
It's basically like joining
the best book club ever
but without actually
having to read anything.
Check out the It's Lit! podcast
in the link in the description below.
Although the first one
that probably comes to mind is getting...
I said... (babbles)
Because we're about to
word-learned like...
Word-learned?
And Shakespeare. (stammers)
Damn it, Jim, I'm not a doctor.
I'm sorry, I am a doctor.
(light music)